>> So the first thing we need to do is actually fetch the graphics context from
the tile its been passed in. Now this is going to be the graphics context that
we're actually going to draw our Bitmaps to. The first think we do here is
actually called fillRect. Just clear the background of this tile in case we
reuse this thing in the future for anything. The next thing we're going to do is
actually create a rectangle that has top, bottom, left, and right parameters
that represent the tile itself. We'll use this here in a second, to pass to the
is visible function. The next thing we do is actually create a vRect object with
a top left bottom and right value that represents the boundaries of the tile
world space. We then walk through each tile for our map, and much like before,
determine whether or not it's visible. Only this time we determine whether or
not it's visible to the passed in canvas rather than the entire viewer. To do
this, we utilize the same intersect rect function passing into vRect that we
created before. And creating a new rectangle that represents the tile that we're
looking at. If the tile is not visible we then, of course, continue on. If it is
visible, we continue with our same process. Modify world x and world y,
offsetting it by our new rectangle values. And then, we call our draw image
function. Now, notice that the draw image actually hasn't changed. In fact, most
of this code is actually identical to your original draw function. Except that
we're now testing tiles against vRect, given from our canvas tile, as well as
drawing to the vRect context.